there are a lot of different types of
forces in physics but for the most part
all forces can be categorized as either
being
a contact force or a long range force
so contact forces as the name suggests
requires the two objects that are
exerting a force on each other to be
touching
or in contact so tension the normal
force frictional forces these are all
common everyday examples of contact
forces
so you know this wire from this crane
can exert a contact force i.e attention
force on the wrecking ball
but that wire can only exert that
tension force on the wrecking ball if
the wire is actually connected to
ie touching the wrecking ball if you
forgot to tie the wire to the wrecking
ball
now wire's not going to exert any
tension on the wrecking ball
so these contact forces are to be
distinguished from
long range forces sometimes these are
called action at a distance forces
because they can be exerted on objects
that are far away from each other
so gravity is a common example the earth
can exert a
gravitational force on the moon even
though the earth and the moon aren't
touching
so that's a long-range force similarly
the electric force can exert a repulsive
force on two charges
if they're not touching so not a contact
force
and magnets can attract each other even
if they're not touching
so those are all long range or action at
a distance forces
but i'll be honest with you here this
distinction is not nearly
as fundamental as it might seem at first
all of these forces
we call contact forces are really just
an enormous number of long-range forces
in disguise in other words these contact
forces tension normal force and friction
are all arising microscopically
due to a bunch of long range forces
acting over really
short distances so just because they're
called long range forces
doesn't mean they can't exert force over
small distances
and in fact all those forces arise you
know cause all these forces to arise so
let me go through
and explain how these come about so
we'll start with tension here
where does tension come from well
tension's the force exerted by a wire
or a cable or a string something like
that and so these strings
they're made out of atoms and molecules
so i'm trying to represent that over
here
your string is probably more than three
atoms wide
but i didn't want to have to draw an
enormous number here so imagine you've
got a certain number of atom
and molecules in your string well these
atoms and molecules are all bonded
together
chemically bonded together those are all
electromagnetic bonds here
and they don't you know they don't want
to move away from their equilibrium
position they have a position and if
they get displaced from there they want
to go back to that spot
so that's what it means to be in a solid
here so this
wire if you connect a heavy load to it
like a wrecking ball that wrecking ball
is going to try to rip these atoms and
molecules apart
it's going to try to pull them away from
each other but they don't want to move
away from each other in other words
they try to restore themselves as this
as this distance between these atoms and
molecules gets bigger
and it does you'll stretch your string
or your wire sometimes imperceptibly
but a little bit as these distances get
bigger
that force holding them together gets
bigger so more tension force occurs and
this is the microscopic origin
of that tension force these atoms and
molecules want to restore themselves to
their
previous length and to do that they have
to pull harder and harder now this won't
last forever
you hang a heavy enough load over here
you'll overwhelm these electromagnetic
bonds and you'll
rip these molecules apart and that's
what happens when your string breaks
so that's the microscopic origin
attention but you don't have to draw
you know an avogadro's number of arrows
we just represent the tension
with one arrow up it turns out you can
pretty much summarize
all of those microscopic electromagnetic
chemical bonds
with one arrow that we call tension
so how about the normal force where does
that come from well this is kind of the
opposite
tension's a pulling force the normal
force is the force that tries to prevent
two
objects from getting smashed into each
other so now instead of the atoms and
molecules trying to get ripped apart
the atoms and molecules in this green
box here due to its weight
are trying to get shoved into the atoms
and molecules of this table so i've
tried to represent that here
again the box and the table are made out
of more than these number of atoms and
molecules
but you've got your atoms molecules of
the box atoms and molecules of the table
they won't get moved into each other
there's going to be an electron cloud
around these atoms and molecules of the
box and similarly for the table
there's going to be an electromagnetic
repulsion when they try to overlap
and other quantum mechanical effects it
turns out it's surprisingly complicated
to explain
why matter is solid and it can't
penetrate each other
but the enormous number of
electromagnetic interactions
and other quantum mechanical effects
between these atoms and molecules are
the microscopic origin
of the normal force so again it's you
know action at a distance
over a small scale which really bugs
people out they're like wait a minute
so am i ever are two things ever
actually touching you know as you sit in
a chair
do the atoms and molecules of your pants
actually physically touch hard to
actually define what it means touching
here so
you know you got these amorphous
electron clouds how do you define
whether they're touching
hard to do but good news we don't have
to do it we can actually just summarize
macroscopically
all of these microscopic interactions as
one
big normal force and that helps us
both calculationally and conceptually
not get too
lost here now you might be disturbed
here you might be like wait a minute
this whole video is about contact forces
you're telling me we don't even know if
two surfaces are in contact well
i'm saying it's hard to define but
here's a good way to define it
your pants atoms and molecules are
contacting the seats atom and molecules
as soon as
you notice that force preventing them
from moving into each other
so as soon as you can detect this normal
force that's as good a way as any to
define two surfaces as being
in contact so let's look at some other
forces
so how about the frictional force what
are the microscopic origins of the
frictional force
well you know the frictional force is
the force that resists
two surfaces from being dragged across
each other
why is there a resistive force well if
you zoomed in on these surfaces
a table no matter how smooth it looks
even if you just wiped it down
if you zoomed in close enough you'd be
shocked at all the little
crevices and cracks and valleys involved
the whole world you don't know about
unless you look at it microscopically
and similarly for this purple box maybe
it's cardboard
if you zoomed in microscopically again
it's astonishing how
not smooth those surfaces are so
obviously if you tried to drag one
across the
other these are bumping into each other
these hills and valleys are running into
each other
that's going to be a problem that's
going to cause a resistive force
you might break this you know yellow
hill off
sometimes they just bust off yep that's
going to be a resistive
cause cause of friction sometimes they
don't bust off maybe they just like
bend and bounce back but even if they do
still going to cause a frictional force
and add to this friction
and it's not just that but sometimes
even like the atoms and molecules
in the surface over here look this spot
doesn't look too bad looks like they
could slide across each other pretty
well
but there can be adhesion like molecular
bonds that form
between those atoms and molecules that
are near each other that can also
contribute to friction
so again astonishingly complicated
there's actually lots of questions to
still be answered
in studying friction the study of
friction is called tribology
uh shockingly a lot of questions to this
day
but the good news is you can summarize
all of those microscopic interactions as
one force we call friction that resists
the two surfaces from sliding over each
other so you don't have to do
a lot of calculations and
microscopically zoom in on the surface
we can pretty much account for all of it
by simply drawing it as one big
resistive force of friction
backwards so recapping contact forces
are those forces that require the two
objects interacting to be touching
for that force to occur but we've seen
that these contact forces are actually
due
to a mind-bogglingly large number of
long-range forces
all acting over a very short distance
but you could summarize
all those long-range forces as a single
contact force
when doing most introductory physics
problems